wir schalten mal live auf den kölner
weihnachtsmarkt zu wird schneider wird
wieso halten sich die immer gleichen
gerüchte über abgesagte sankt martin
züge und weihnachtsmärkte so hartnäckig
sie haben aber auch nichts gelernt 2016
da in ihrer medien blase oder auch
eingebildete ängste sind ängste man hier
geht es um unsere christliche kultur
wir feiern die geburt unseres herrn
indem wir uns ab 12 uhr mittags brutal
gezuckerten bülow rotwein mit kerosin
reinmüller wer uns eine endlos version
von last christmas den letzten klaren
gedanken von der festplatte pustet so
wie gott es gewollt hat das hat gott
gewollt ja klar
und dann geht mein arsch voll geld aus
für irgendwelche potthässlich dem man
nur leute schenken kann die man wirklich
abgrundtief hasst
schauen sie mal oliver schauen sie mal
ich hab ihnen einen kaffeebecher gekauft
mit der beste chef der welt drauf auch
danke
wir dürfen den muslimen nicht nachgeben
was kommt dann als nächstes darf ich
karfreitag bald ein schwein falsch mehr
essen oder wie du wenn wir nicht
höllisch aufpassen da kriegen wir
demnächst ganz neue feiertage so was wie
gründonnerstag ja alle halten
booz & burkhardt oder noch besser
christi himmelfahrt
ihre murat lasse man die luft raus ja
genau und den nikolaus wird zwangs
beschnitten was ist denn das für ein
alberner quatsch
das nennt man brauchtumspflege sie at
ist zum beispiel der uralte christliche
brauch bei jedem weihnachtsmarkt besucht
die zwei meter lange bratwurst komplett
runter zu bürgen
so von sehnen und mettenheim und lecker
viele vielleicht essen sie die nach
unserer schalte weitere genau das wollen
die doch sicher wird es schneien dabei
damen und herren
[Applaus]